un budget adapté à la co vide pour le
département en 2021 acteurs de la
politique sociale sur le territoire
le conseil départemental des yvelines va
notamment consacrer 183 6 millions
d'euros au versement du revenu de
solidarité active soit 15% de plus qu'en
2020 une obligation puisque le nombre de
bénéficiaires a augmenté de plus de 6%
dans les yvelines ce qui est lié à
l'augmentation du chômage longue durée
qui est lié à la fois à la crise
sanitaire et à une vieille crise
yvelinoise qui perdure qui est celle de
la crise industrielle
les yvelines qui sont d'un département
industriel ont vu beaucoup de ces
industries sous la force de la
concurrence étrangère a baissé pavillon
avec un budget de 1,6 milliard d'euros
le département des yvelines peut compter
sur le maintien de ses recettes sans
augmentation d'impôts les compensations
et les dotations augmentation stable
donc c'est pour nous une douce ce nouvel
et nous avons une bonne tenue d'une
recette fiscales importantes que sont
les droits de mutation nous sommes assez
optimistes là dessus le département
poursuit aussi ses investissements dans
le soutien aux communes la rénovation
urbaine ou encore dans la mobilité une
enveloppe globale de 467 millions
d'euros tout en restant attentif à la
crise sanitaire
vous avez vu que le département est
parce qu il ya une gestion extrêmement
parcimonieuse extrêmement réfléchi
et plutôt en bonne situation financière
s'il faut je le redis utiliser cette
bonne santé financière pour financer des
opérations qu'on n'avait pas l'habitude
de financer dans le cadre de la pandémie
nous le saurons le département a par
exemple débloqué 15 millions d'euros
pour venir en aide aux commerçants